politics makes very strange bedfellows
we're in a situation now i never thought
we would be in
which is that the conservative
republican president hates fox news
trump
trump hates fox news
trump used to love fox news and fox used
to love trump
conservatives used to love fox news fox
used to love conservatives
now do you know who loves fox news brian
stelter at cnn we did talk about fox
news and he's very disappointed
at fox news at very crucial moments uh
the debate
chris wallace is moderating was terrible
really hurt i think
uh the president and then you know they
called the election
they called arizona with 14 of the vote
in
many other networks never called it
meanwhile they wouldn't call florida for
hours
why what was going on at fox news that
they didn't want to give the president
the sense
that he was winning or had the potential
shot of winning
fox has a great decision desk i respect
their decision desk they don't they
don't they don't do it like that they
don't play games like that chris
i think media malpractice let's look at
the fox news poll it was off by
what eight points almost every poll was
and
the data coming out of fox was not good
at all yeah we're going to get into the
polls but but the fox
the fox polls were scientific they were
trying their best
i love the oh i love fox news yeah we
here at cnn man last couple days man
we've just been
loving fox news frankly they made us
blush a little bit when they called
arizona
for joe biden before anybody and for no
reason whatsoever
he said fox slow it down i know you want
to you want to seem like us for a couple
days but come on so anyway in conclusion
chris
and no we we love fox news over here at
cnn now
that was chris ruddy by the way uh chris
ruddy is the head of newsmax which is a
conservative competitor to fox and
newsmax has remained
quite conservative you know this
this changing of the guard this changing
of political perspectives on cable news
reminds us among these established
outlets there is no conservative voice
there isn't one we thought there was
but there isn't it's all against
conservatives and now it seems it's
against the president i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you